oh my god the talent of these people in
this show it is unbelievable the train
the years of dedication and sacrifice
they had to do to get here all i had to
do was be born missing a chromosome
it's new york city's wildest night out
in vegas and the newest show on the
strip we are talking about mad apple at
new york new york hotel and casino and
joining me from the show is comedian
brad williams welcome thank you so much
that's right uh cirque du soleil always
original and they had the completely
original idea of putting a dwarf in the
circus never been done before
never i mean though this is originally
with comedians in the cirque show that
has never happened yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm like the neil armstrong uh of
comedians only it's way smaller steps uh
but yes they they've never done stand-up
comics in a cirque show before this is a
this is a new concept for them and
what's so cool about it is that whereas
someone doing the more traditional
cirque acrobatics their act kind of has
to be the same every night the comedians
can change we can adjust if something
happens during the show we can comment
on it um one of our shows there was a
man who had way too much fun in vegas
and he actually passed out intoxicated
in the theater i walked out i noticed
him i ran off the stage and i started
hitting him in the head with the
microphone to wake him up
and
the guy that's yeah the guy that it did
he woke up saw a dwarf and his first
reaction was i'm pretty sure i get three
wishes now um but
uh he
but he enjoyed it and that's something
that the guys doing the traditional
acrobatics don't get to do so that's why
it's so much fun well it's it's a a
bunch of things in the show it's comedy
it's it's acrobatics it's uh rapping
like
tell us give us how do you describe the
show
it is cirque for the add audience do you
like acrobats cool we have them if you
don't like that we have musicians cool
you don't like that cool we got guys
jumping off trampolines we have
freestyle rapping comedians we have
magicians we have close-up magicians we
have big trick magicians whatever like
basically this is like five cirque shows
in one that's like a swiss army knife
and then you throw in dwarf and that's
just like little cherry on top i love it
i love it how was opening night i've
heard rave reviews about this yeah uh
opening night was very exciting uh the
energy in the room what we're really
trying to do we don't want people to sit
back in their chairs and be like well
this is a lovely night at the fiat
like that's not what we're going for
we're going for the audience to be part
of the show we we feed off their energy
we want you to sing we want you to be a
part of it and uh that and we had
celebrities come out uh anderson pack
came out to the premiere part of the
show did you make it part of it we did a
little something with him uh wrestler
chris jericho came out to the show so it
was a big
it it was a big spectacle and it felt
really cool to be a part of a big
spectacle on the vegas strip well you're
originally from orange county so i
assume that you probably came to vegas a
few times a few times
we've had some bachelor parties here uh
we we we've had some stories that i
can't say well so what's the difference
now between visiting vegas and actually
living here and working here in vegas oh
like going to the local spots yeah i'm
really excited about going to local
restaurants where the tourists aren't or
they don't know about it there's so many
hidden gems in vegas that i didn't
realize that this city spreads so much
further beyond just the strip yeah
there's so much other cool stuff out
there i'm currently living in henderson
and there's so many like great
restaurants cool things to do and i'm
really having a blast i went on a boat
on lake mead uh we only found two bodies
yeah so i feel like a local now i
discovered a body hey
you are so funny and i'm so excited that
you are part of the show which again has
just been getting rave reviews new york
new york yes you're local now yeah matt
apple lv.com get your tickets uh and
come be a part of the most exciting
night in vegas it's gonna be a great
time again matt apple performing new
york new york friday through tuesday
there are two shows nightly 7 p.m and 9
30 p.m ticket prices start at 59 they're
available at mad apple lv.com and uh due
to adult themes and content uh children
under 16 are not permitted
all right